victories and losses look the same in
this war a trail of Destruction and
death
in the village of blau.net the bodies of
Russian soldiers still lay in the grass
the smell of their decomposing corpses
fills the air
but there's no time to hang around here
the Russians are just 1.5 kilometers
away and constantly shelling only 10
people remain here Nina is one of those
who refuse to leave
when the Russians entered there were a
lot of them it was very scary but when
our guys liberated us then I became
Karma all our family homes have been
destroyed but we will rebuild we will do
it gradually when our boys advance and
these shells don't fall on our heads
getting this close to Russian positions
is usually not allowed but Commander
Andre on his track in Ukraine's 68th
Brigade wanted to show us what his
soldiers have achieved
hurry move this place is being hit he
says we drive along the front lines
closer and closer to Russian positions
there's no slowing down or stopping here
shells Fall by the roadside just missing
us as we speed past
that was close I was falling asleep
using the trees discover we Traverse
through off-road tracks city is Russia
Andrea's drone team is within ice shot a
Russian occupied positions in pavlivka
hidden within dense foliage were within
motor artillery and tank range it's why
this team is so small and operating with
complete secrecy
all that separates these soldiers and
Russians of fields
before the war Andrea was a well-known
businessman with his own TV show
he joined the Ukrainian military along
with his son ostap when the war started
his son was killed last month
I don't understand how it could have
happened I realized he wanted me to see
him as a hero it was very important for
him I didn't realize it was so important
for him when he was alive but I realized
now he was looking for ways to show me
I was a strict father and I rarely
praised him but at the same time I was
very demanding and I always pointed out
his mistakes and it put pressure on him
he wanted to be the best he could for me
and he became the best
Andrea still has a job to do though his
team has managed to find a potential
Target they arm the Drone With Grenades
this drone crew have managed to locate
some Russian soldiers that are dug in
below the tree line now the Drone is
hovering just over those positions where
they hope to drop some grenades right
onto those Russian positions
Andrea gives the order to drop the
grenades Andrea says his team kills up
to 12 soldiers a day
the story of this war is one of personal
sacrifice and us and for ukrainians it's
still not over
eastern Ukraine